Build it.
Draw it.
Play it.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build it.
Peter Lynn created a 100 foot blue whale kite.
The New Zealand engineer and inventor has
been making kites since 1977 with this realistically
looking blue whale carrying a price tag of
over $6000.
Lynn has a bunch of other incredible kites
including a horse, a crocodile and an alien
spaceship.
Italian artist Franco Recchia builds city
sculptures using computer parts.
He says he's always had a passion for taking
things apart and reassembling them in large
compositions made up processors and mechanical
parts and his has a huge variety of pieces
in a similar style in his portfolio.
Photographer David A Reeves creates action
vignettes made from cut-paper silhouettes.
He builds the miniature sets with layers that
create a depth of field and his works include
scenes from batman, the wild west and a samurai
duel.
The Pulse Sensor is a plug and play heart
rate sensor made by Joel Murphy and Yuri Gitman.
It allows a person's pulse to be incorporated
into arduino projects - so heart rate and
be used in video games, apps or music visualizations.
Draw it.
Marlin Peterson painted giant spiders on a
roof in Seattle.
The mural was originally going to be on a
wall but when he couldn't find one large enough
he decided to use a roof that's visible from
the Space Needle.
And it creates the illusion that enormous
daddy long legs are taking over the Seattle
Center Armory.
Mark Crilley has an incredible YouTube channel
that aspiring artists should check out.
He has recently been doing realism challenges
where he attempts to accurately draw an object
like crumbled paper, playing card and more
- find the link below.
Now for the incredible illustrations of Sam
Spratt...
Anatomical monsters is a series by illustrator
Brad McGinty that takes a look at the guts
of some of the most famous pop culture creatures
including Predator, a martian from Mars Attacks
and a Gremlin.
Play It.
Sonification Of Everyday Objects was created
by dennis paul and it scans the surface of
objects and turns them into audible frequencies...
The Algae Opera feed algae with the singers
breath which is enhanced by the amount of
breath so a well-trained singer apparently
produces high-quality edible algae product...
Rainboard is an isomorphic instrument with
62 arcade buttons with LEDs embedded in them
hooked up to an iOS app to configure the buttons...
Vsauce!
Hey, I got a play it bidipi!
Oh hey Nathan Barnatt - if you got a play
it let's see it!
It's a dance...it's called "Works It"
Submit your own BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube.
Or share them with everyone at facebook.com/vsaucegaming.
Click here to listen to bidipi radio.
Music created and submitted by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to your creations.
And as always... thanks for watching.